i'm proud to tell you
that just days ago we announced that a
record-breaking 14 and a half million
americans got themselves a health
insurance plan that they could afford
through the affordable care act and its
recent open enrollment period now let me
go ahead and take off this mask
that's an important number because while
the 14.5 million is big
what you really want to know here in
virginia is that
more than 300 000 of those americans are
virginians who now have health insurance
and the peace of mind that comes from
knowing you can take your child to a
hospital
without going bankrupt because of the
bill
the president's american rescue plan
which congresswoman spamberger helped
get across the finish line helped lower
the average monthly premium on those
insurance policies by 26
for those virginians
that's more money staying in your pocket
because you're hard-working americans
and you deserve it in fact
thanks to the president's american
rescue plan four in five people in
america who recently signed up for the
health insurance
offered under the affordable care act
could find a health plan
where they paid 10 or less per month
in premiums
ten dollars
a month in premiums now that's a good
deal
the president also has us hard at work
fighting to lower the cost of the
prescription prescription drugs
that you use day in and day out and that
you need
he's heard the stories from americans in
every corner of our country
americans like alex smith in minnesota
who couldn't afford
the medication he needed
alec a 26 year old father
died
after trying to ration his insulin
because he was trying to make ends meet
we paid too much for prescription drugs
in america
on average
about fifteen hundred dollars
per person
and if you're saying to yourself right
now
hey
i don't use prescription medication so i
don't have any of those costs
well just think how much your uncle or
your neighbor
must be paying so that when taken
together
it adds up to an average of one thousand
five hundred dollars a year for each and
every one of us
in america
we pay more than any comparable nation
for our life-saving medications
you know what that means
well
price gouging means americans face
impossible choices
refill your gas tank
or refill your
prescription medication
get life-saving meds
or keep a roof over your family's head
when alex smith's mother testified
before congress she said
this should never happen
and i am counting on all of you to help
make sure it does not happen to another
family
that's why last fall
we rolled out a comprehensive plan to
lower prescription drug prices through
real competition negotiating for the
best price
and sparking new
innovative treatments
our work isn't finished
and it takes all of us
because we know health care is not just
about mending bones
or dispensing pills
it's about giving people peace of mind
so
thank you president biden
thank you for keeping your promise to
make health care more affordable and for
giving americans a chance
to secure the peace of mind
they deserve
now of course
none of our progress would be possible
without strong leadership of congress
that's why i'm proud to introduce our
next speaker
abigail spamberger came to congress to
protect americans access to affordable
health care like me
she knows that raising three daughters
means providing
the health
the safety
and the chance to thrive to our children
and for the past three years she has
advocated for bipartisan health care
solutions that achieve real progress
and respond to the unique challenges
of rural communities in america
please join me today in welcoming your
congresswoman abigail spamber
hello my name is abigail spanberger and
i am proud to serve virginia's seventh
district each and every day in congress
on behalf of our district i'd like to
welcome president biden and his team to
culpepper county welcome to our
commonwealth mr president
thank you secretary becerra for your
introduction and thank you for your
attention to the rising cost of
prescription drugs
i look forward to working closely with
you in the future
thank you to mayor reeves and members of
the culpepper town council for being
with us today
today i am proud to bring the president
of the united states here to one of the
campuses of germanna mr president this
institution
does tremendous workforce training and
they truly have a heart
for not just the careers of their
students but also for their well-being
if anyone in your administration has
questions about how to get the next
generation prepared
and to how to keep our country
competitive i would encourage them to
look no further than this place
throughout the pandemic places like
culpepper have looked out for their
neighbors people have banded together
and they've supported small businesses
first responders police and health care
workers all of whom make our communities
stronger we have seen tremendous
progress in the battle against this
virus but even in the midst of this
moment of recovery our communities still
struggle with the sticker price of many
items including and especially at the
pharmacy counter
covid has exacerbated what was always
already
a staggering day-to-day cost for
virginia families and we are long
overdue in addressing it today is about
bringing renewed focus and more
importantly urgency to lowering drug
prices since i first ran for congress
this issue has been top of mind for my
constituents they are outraged that in
the united states of america they have
to pay 10 times as much or more
as patients in other countries pay for
the same medication
for our neighbors with common health
conditions like diabetes heart disease
or cancer i consistently hear about how
skyrocketing drug prices are making it
harder to stay ahead and harder to plan
for the future
i hear about delayed payments on rent or
the mortgage i hear about parents
sitting at the dining room table and
deciding whether they should drain their
child's education fund to help pay for
their child's medication
and i hear from seniors who are skipping
a meal because they cannot afford the
medication they need to survive
these are the personal experiences of
virginians of the virginians i represent
but if you were to throw a dart anywhere
on the map of the united states you
would hear these exact same stories
part of our recovery means stopping
these stories from remaining a common
refrain
in congress i welcome any effort that
can deliver lower drug prices for the
people i serve it is worth our time
because giving medicare the power to
negotiate drug prices and giving
virginians peace of mind about an aging
parent or relative that is worth our
time
and capping the price of insulin so that
kids can just be kids
and not have to worry about another trip
to the er that is worth our time
and holding drug companies and pdms
accountable for increasing the prices
that cancer patients pay
all behind a shroud of secrecy that is
worth our time and lawmakers have spent
a lot of time
talking about lowering drug costs and we
know the american people are behind this
push but we need to buck up and get it
done
the virginians who are with us today
have their stories
of how high drug costs have impacted
them and congress needs to demonstrate
that we are not just listening to them
not just talking to them but we are
delivering for them
and now i have the honor of introducing
one such 7th district family with a
powerful story
shannon davis is a dedicated teacher and
she's here with her son joshua and for
the record joshua is one of the bravest
constituents i have ever met and he's
already becoming one of the strongest
advocates on this issue meeting with our
office calling for changes to practices
of drug middlemen and speaking out on
behalf of kids like him with type 1
diabetes
if we all displayed the leadership and
the maturity of joshua i think we'd be
able to tackle way more challenges than
just the rising cost of prescription
drugs i am proud to know the davis
family and i am proud to know that they
are using their story to bring much
needed attention to out of pocket costs
and how they are impacting them and
their neighbors
it is now my honor to introduce the
president of the united states president
joe biden and shannon and joshua davis
[Applause]
oh
thank you so much to congresswoman
spanberger and president biden for
reaching out to us to be able to share
our story with you today
our story represents just one of the
millions of americans who live with
chronic illnesses that require life
life-saving medication every single day
brian my husband was diagnosed at the
age of 28
with type 1 diabetes previously known as
juvenile diabetes an autoimmune disease
that stops your body from creating
insulin
at 28 years old
that was such a surprise for a young
couple married
to realize that brian would need this
insulin for the rest of his life
this quickly became overwhelming when
joshua our second child was diagnosed
before his first birthday
at the time we had no idea how
prescription the prescription and
medical costs would impact our future as
a family
we are extremely privileged that we have
maintained insurance for the last 17
years
insurance for the last 17 years however
even with insurance we currently spend
between six and seven thousand dollars a
year
that is just our insulin cost this does
not include the insulin pump supplies
emergency glucagon monitoring or test
strips
we have worked hard over the last 12
years since joshua was diagnosed and we
have figured out ways to conserve our
insulin when possible
you learn tricks to save money with this
life-threatening disease
we will use one vial between brian and
joshua until its every last drop is gone
we will use insulin after it is expired
even though it's not recommended and we
will push our pump sites just a little
bit longer than we should
we'll space out when we pick up our new
prescriptions because in january when
our new high deductible has hit we do
not have thousands of dollars to go into
the pharmacy
and spend that money on our insulin
everyone's experience is unique and i
have met so many families that have had
to skip insulin doses or choose between
their house and their electric bills or
their child's insulin for the month
joshua is only 12 years old and on
february 13th he will have lived with
type 1 diabetes for 12 years
and god willing he will have many more
years ahead of him
and in those years
i am hopeful that when he is an adult
as a country we will have recognized
that these crucial medications need to
be affordable for all americans
if insulin costs were capped at 35 per
month this would be life changing not
only for our family but for the millions
of families impacted by diabetes
i am so thankful for the leaders who are
working so hard on behalf of our
families and the rest of the the
americans to make this a reality
at this time i would be honored to
introduce you to one of my heroes my son
joshua davis
thank you
thank you for inviting me to share my
story
my name is joshua davis and i am 12
years old and in the 7th grade at swift
creek middle school in chesterfield va
i am excited i am active in scouts and
love playing goalie with my cyl lacrosse
team
i was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes at
11 months old
so my entire life this is all i have
ever known
and until there is a cure all i will
know
before getting my insulin pump i needed
10 to 12 shots of insulin a day
uh but my insulin pump changed that
but
while i am getting older i also need
more insulin every day
i have to be careful with my bottles of
insulin because they can break very
easily and well i am a 12 year old boy
it helps that my dad also has type 1
diabetes
he's truly my hero for showing me how to
live with type 1 diabetes
i am thankful that insulin was invented
because because it is my life support i
don't have a choice whether or not to
use it
i lead a very active life and i don't
let type 1 slow me down i'm thankful
that my parents do what they can to make
sure i have insulin
thank you so much to congresswoman
spamberger and president biden for all
they are doing to make sure i i will be
able to continue to live safely and
actively with affordable insulin
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president of the united states president
biden
thank you mr president
i could have no more done that
when i was 12 years old than fly
i used to be a stutter i was scared to
death i would stand up and to to
talk talk like that
and i can't tell you how much how proud
i am of you
and your brother's equally as impressive
as you are he's standing there he's
sitting there two seats over
shannon and joshua
and by the way happy birthday man he's
gonna be 13 years old teenager a couple
days
[Applause]
i want you to know that lowering the
cost of prescription drugs is one of the
reasons why i'm here with abigail your
congresswoman
and that's what i want to talk about
with you today
lowering the cost to health care overall
as well lowering the cost of
prescription drugs is important and
giving families like yours just a little
bit more breathing room
makes a gigantic difference
before i get into that i want to say
it's good to be here at
germana school by the way
abigail if i want to know anything about
community colleges in virginia i go to
my wife
she teaches full-time and has for the
last nine years she's in the classroom
now
at
community college in northern virginia
northern virginia community college and
she says she says you know
the single best kept secret in america
is community colleges and it really is
they are so flexible they can do so much
so much
and if i had more time which i don't for
all of you i'd go into what we're going
to try to do to increase the flexibility
and the funding of community colleges
for people but
it's great to be here with abigail with
congresswoman spamberger
in every chapter of her career in every
chapter she's always been about one
thing
service
service
i also want to thank mark warner and tim
kaine your senators here good friends
and worked closely with men so many
things when i was a senator and now as
president and when i was vice president
but they needed to be in washington
today because there's votes in the
senate
i also want to thank secretary of health
and human services javier barcera for
two things one
for answering my call when i asked him
to come and be a secretary i was worried
he wouldn't
and uh and how much he's helped us make
so much progress in getting people
vaccinated
getting health insurance and making
more affordable health care
look health care is part of abigail
congresswoman
are your congresswoman's
background
back in 2017
she saw her representatives in congress
vote to repeal the affordable care act
that was one of more than 100 republican
efforts there were 100 republican
efforts since we passed it in our last
administration to repeal the affordable
care act
but she knew that
that was the exact opposite of what
central virginia
badly needed
you need it then and you need now more
access to quality health care that is
more affordable
so when i became president united states
that's what we did we passed the
american rescue plan
which made quality coverage through the
affordable care act more affordable than
ever before
with families saving on average who
signed up family on average two thousand
four hundred dollars a year in their
annual premiums
compared to last year the average
monthly premium virginians for
virginians has gone down more than 25
percent
over five million people have gained
coverage through the aca since i became
president
and as i mentioned by javier over 300
000 virginians
have signed up for health insurance
during the open enrollment period here
in virginia
and we want to go further
long prescription drug prices get a cap
on the amount people pay
on medicare pay for prescription drugs
and to bring more clarity and fewer
surprises when you get your bills if
you've been hospitalized so let me say a
few words about each of these things now
with regard to prescription drugs
in america
we pay the highest
prescription drug prices of any nation
developed nation in the world the
highest of any and it's about two to
three times higher than what other
countries pay
let me give you one example
an anti-cancer drug to treat leukemia
and lymphoma
cost 14 000 a month in the united states
the same exact drug
made by the same exact pharmaceutical
company
is sold in france
and it's six thousand dollars a month
six thousand for the same exact drug
same
exact manufacturer
same exact amounts
not 14 but six
that's for a month's supply
today one in four americans who need
prescription drugs struggle to afford
them one in four
nearly 30 percent have skipped doses of
essential drugs they're supposed to take
others have simply not filled
prescriptions that the doctor had given
them
tried to use over-the-counter drugs or
pills cut in half
because they can't afford the cost of
their prescription
this is the united states of america for
god's sake
that's just wrong it's simply wrong
especially since it doesn't cost a drug
company nearly nearly nearly nearly as
much
to make the drug or the research that
went into them
let me regress for just a moment here
i started when in the in the
obama biden administration
a effort to deal with
a cancer moonshot to change the way in
which we deal with cancer and i'm
reinstituting that in my administration
now
it was interesting i met we had these
hearings all over the united states
and
one of the major events we did we used
at howard university where there were
35 other events going on simultaneously
with this
i subsequently met with the heads of i
think it was 13 drug companies
and i asked him i said if you found a
cure
for particular cancer
how much you think you should be able to
charge
and the response universally was what
the market will bear
i said hope i don't get elected
president
because that's just not what you'll get
should be treated more like a utility
you should be able to make a significant
progress for it let's add up how much
and like they do in germany
how much does it cost you all the
research and development all the effort
add it all up
and then on top of that add a
significant premium for it
a profit of
20 to 30 percent above that
maybe in some cases more
but the idea
the idea
you can charge whatever you want
is just not going to happen in the
united states of america if i have
anything to do with it
if you think this doesn't affect you it
does by the way
everyone has less money in their pockets
a day because of high drug price drug
cost and health insurance
and it's more expensive for everyone
and the reason it is
is this is what your insurance companies
pay every all you have insurance
you're paying a heck of a lot more even
if you're not using the drugs
over the past decade health care costs
have gone up 50
prescription drugs are a big chunk of
that
and there's a lot of things that almost
every american can agree on
but i think it's safe to say that all of
us
whatever our background our age where we
live whether we're grand prescription
drugs
look we all acknowledge they're
outrageously expensive
and in many cases very no relationship
to cost
doesn't need to be that way
josh and shannon
it cost drug companies less than ten
dollars to make a vial of that insulin
less than ten bucks
that's what it cost
there's no reason you should be paying
over three hundred dollars a while for
medicine you need every day to stay
healthy and in many cases stay alive
as your mom said
you got to pay 5 600 for prescriptions
before your insurance even kicks in you
got to do the deductible
shannon
you should have peace of mind of knowing
that joshua grows up and leaves
your your care your health care plan
he'll be able to choose a job
without ever having to make a choice
between which one has the particular
health care coverage
you know we're now in a position where
we can cap co-pays
for insulin
at 35 a month
it's still a staggering profit three and
a half times what it costs to produce
the drug
you can do that with the stroke of we
can do that with a stroke of a pen
in my build back better legislation that
with abigail's leadership past the house
of representatives
we can do that now we just have to get
it through the united states senate
and we're close
we can do even more to lower
out-of-pocket prescription costs under
my proposal
we will hold drug companies accountable
for the absurd price increases here's
how
drug companies have increased their
prices faster than the rate of inflation
once the price is set will face a steep
tax
this will help us end the days when drug
companies can increase their prices with
no oversight no accountability and no
responsibility
we're saying to drug companies
you are finally going to become
accountable when you raise prices on the
american people
accountability
you're still going to make a significant
profit
we can take additional steps to lower
drug costs for people with medicare
something abigail has championed
right now
the only thing medicare is not allowed
to negotiate
the price of our prescription drugs
for everything else covered by medicare
a doctor's visit they negotiate and
we'll pay no more than this much for a
doctor's visit
so the doctors don't want to take any
medicare patients they don't have to
but if they have a medicare patient
which are millions of them
they cannot charge more than a certain
amount of crutches
we limit the amount of money they can
pay for crutches
but
but
medicare can negotiate everything except
drug prices
the only outfit they can't do they can't
deal with
my plan is going to allow medicare to
negotiate the prices they're prepared to
pay for each individual drug
if the company says i'm not going to i'm
not going to sell it to that price fine
but they're going to lose millions of
customers
millions of customers
we're proposing what we're proposing
is that we negotiate fair prices one
that reflects the cost of research and
development and the need for significant
profit but still is affordable and has
some relationship to the cost of drug
companies
my plan also caps the amount that
seniors on medicare have to spend on
prescription drugs each year total
so that if they're on medicare they'll
not have to spend out a pocket more than
two thousand dollars a year no matter
how many drugs they're taking
but drug companies insurance companies
and medicine
and medicare picking up the rest of the
cost
and just last month to bring greater
chance period to health care costs my
administration outlawed surprise billing
i've had uh a
significant experience
with uh
with hospital care
my son beau
who was attorney general of delaware and
uh
won the bronze star in iraq and excuse
me and
uh dealing with
being
deployed overseas for a long time
for a year
you know he uh he came back with
glioblastoma
he died
but you know what
uh you know the fact is that uh
and i i was hospitalized a long time and
a couple years ago cranial aneurysms
hospitalized for a long time
and you can no longer get that surprise
buildings we got
if your health care plan did not cover a
particular doctor but you didn't even
know you're being consulted you get an
extra bill for two to five thousand
dollars they can't do that anymore
no more surprise billing
no more
millions of hard-working americans will
no longer have to worry about unexpected
medical bills and abigail has been
making sure
that we bring the same transparency to
drug prices
a couple years ago abigail worked to
pass a bipartisan legislation to make
drug prices more transparent so you knew
what you were paying for
my administration is working with
abigail to make sure we enforce that
she also has been relentless in making
sure the laws that's been on the books
that says pharmaceutical companies need
to provide rural clinics and community
health centers with discounts on
prescription drugs it's actually
enforced
we're working together on that as well
i've long said health care should be a
right not a privilege in this country
this is an important
diabetes alzheimer's cancer they're not
partisan issues they're not democrat or
republican
this is about this about whether or not
you and your loved ones can afford the
health care you need and the medic and
the medicines you need to stay healthy
because we need to ease the burden on
working families by making everything
more affordable and accessible
look again slight digression inflation
is up
it's up
and coming from a family when the price
of gas went up you felt it in the
household you knew what it was like it
matters
but the fact is that
if we are able to do the things i'm
talking about here
it'll bring down the cost for average
families
bring down the cost for average families
i don't know why they keep moving all
that but the fact is they keep down the
cost for average families
and look
the fact is that we're in a situation
now where
um
you know you should have peace of mind
know food prices are up and we're
working to bring them down as i said i
grew up in a family where
the price of the pump went up you fill
it and i understand
but these things are necessities
we're working to bring down prices where
they're not totally what families
in fact
have to pay now
you still have to pay for child care
child care is a cost for millions of
families you still have to pay your
prescription drug prices you still have
to pay for health care
you want to lower the cost of living for
people help them in those areas
so there's more than one way for a
family
when it comes to
raising their standard of living
i'm going to work like the devil to
bring gas prices down which i'm going to
work in to make sure that we keep
strengthening the supply chains to bring
the cost of energy and everything else
and the goods that come to america
down
by helping the porch 24 7 by changing a
whole range of things that you know
what's happened with covet cova has
caused significant increase in prices in
the supply chain
because when the factory shuts down
another part of the world and you need
that particular product in order to
finish and build whatever you're working
on the price goes up exponentially like
for cars but in the meantime
there's a lot we can do to give families
extra breathing room
we can do this when we cut the cost of
child care making sure that you don't
pay more than seven percent of the
family's income for child care
it saves thousands of dollars in
families for families
shannon think about what these plans
would mean for you and your family
we've already made a lot of progress on
the economy
last year more jobs were created in
america than in any year in american
history
unemployment has dropped more than any
year in american history
we reduced the deficit the federal
deficit while doing those both those
things by 300 billion dollars
we lowered child poverty by nearly 40
percent in america
more than any year in american history
as a consequence of the child tax credit
and we're coming out in these challenges
in the position of strength unmatched by
any nation in the world and i might add
and i note here
that
this does not raise anyone's if you're
making less than 400 000 you're not
paying a single penny more in taxes
not a single penny more in taxes
and it does not increase the debts
because it's paid for
it's fully paid for
i've had a group of major companies from
intel to general motors to ford
across the board
come to me and say they want to keep
these programs going increase corporate
taxes to 24 which they were supposed to
be
it gets paid for they understand the net
effect on the economy is to grow it
we know that we invest in ourselves
there's no limit to what we can achieve
with leaders like abigail and then the
brave folks are like shannon and joshua
all of you know here today that all this
progress we made is going to be just the
beginning
just the beginning
i promise you
we're going to do so much more
and it will not i emphasize it will not
increase the debt it will not increase
taxes on anyone making less than 400 000
a year
and by the way i'm a capitalist
a capitalist
you should be able to make a million or
a billion dollars just pay a little bit
of your fair share that's all
we over 53 companies in america
that made 40 billion last year
didn't pay a single penny in taxes
not a single penny
that's not right
and so you find a lot of these
corporations realize to grow and be
competitive it makes sense just to pay a
little more in taxes at the top end
in order to afford this economic growth
were created
but bringing down the cost of health
care
bringing down the cost of prescription
drugs
is an
easy thing for us to do
it can be done legally with a stroke of
a pen
we got to kind of get abigail's
enthusiasm that she got it through in
the house of representatives the united
states senate so maybe dragging you over
to the senate spend some time
but all kidding aside there's so much we
can do
and i want to thank the family for being
willing to stand up here and share their
story
and dad stand up so everybody knows who
you are i wanted to see you
that good-looking guy back there that's
dead
[Applause]
every time i'd walk out of my grandpop's
house up in scranton pennsylvania
his name was ambrose finnegan he was an
all-american football player
out of santa clara when he was a kid
and he used to always yell joey keep the
faith
my grandmother really yelled back no
joey spread it
let's spread the faith and get this done
thank you very very much
[Applause]
so
[Music]
find it